Albert Bandura is a famous psychologist known for his research on social
learning. He conducted a series of really well known studies that showed us how
sensitive we were to learning from the consequences of other people. And he did
so using this guy. A bobo doll. The famous 1960s bobo doll case focused on two
areas of social learning, modeling and reinforcement. Modeling is a term that
Van Duren used to describe the process of observing and imitating behaviors
performed by other people. Now, reinforcement is just like with
[INAUDIBLE]
conditioning where we add something to increase the frequency of the behavior.
Van Duren noted that people will do things other people do especially if they
are rewarded for it.